j'en suis arrivée de osmont soir muriel
robin c'est l'actualité qui vous fait
rire comme ça du tout non mais attends
je suis une comique je me dis je c'est
drôle je voulais me suis ravi des
attaques alliées on va croire tout ce
que tu suis ravi de vous accueillir
parce que parce que je vous aime tous
les deux et on vous aime tous les deux
parce que vous allez vous unir à
l'olympia sur scène
ah oui sur scène à l'olympia le 13
octobre alors ravi et surpris parce que
les monstres sacrés mètres seul evry
partagez vous allez partager la lumière
là c'est vraiment c'est si rare mais oui
c'est rare et c'est pour ça qu'on le
fait c'est pour se faire remarquer oui
davantage de poids plus comment dire les
choses pourquoi est ce qu'on fait les
choses là vous pourriez de l'union c'est
vrai qu'on n'explique pas plus ce genre
de 100 buts
l'airé petit avait préparé voulu faire
un petit compliment à tous la marne on
n'a pas le compliment
non le complément c'est maintenant le
compliment j'ai déjà dit cela c'est la
moindre des choses mais nous voilà avant
des comédiens aller vers les artistes
marrant dit tiens toi qui me plaît c'est
bien ce qu'elles sont c'est un truc
ensemble c'est plus évident en musique
ou en général les banques cherchent à
jouer avec les bons généralement ils se
reconnaissent en musique c'est plus
précisément leur comment alors se
couvrir le partage des vastes justement
là justement le partage il va s'opérer
couilles c'est l'indépendance
associations ou la fusion alors alors
oui les mots compliqués
c'est en fait c'est un panaché c'est un
panaché de ce que vous venez de dire
c'est à la fois l'indépendance j'espère
qu'il va lâcher un peu en dehors des
heures de service
et puis en même temps c'est la fusion
parce que parce que voilà ça va décoller
c'est qu iliad équipe d'envoyé spécial
qui a filmé pendant deux mois votre
rencontre
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
dépassera le 8 octobre oui ça va être
bien
alors regardez envoyé spécial de mini
colonna bon ils ont réalisé cette merci
bien
formidable qui toute l'équipe regardez
ce bonne foi trois plans non plus
à
eh oui
comment
ce sera ni un soldat de robben ni un
spectacle de glo s'assurera cette espèce
de collisions de musique modifié car
elle sera pas tout à fait leur banc
habituel et je serais peut-être pas tout
à fait je suis d'habitude non plus
il ya un phénomène de chimie dedans on
réagit l'un par rapport à l'eau
je
c'est vrai
vous pensez bien
il par exemple pas trop mal mais
d'ailleurs je vous faire un jeu vous
faire mûriers a permis d'aller marquer
d'entrée bien gardé les gros orteil
mille marines
là vous répétiez vous allez danser
comment à l'olympia détresse dire que
toute une partie il ya le spectacle
devrait deux heures il ya une heure et
quart donc de balle c'était bien vrai
nom il ya une partie qui ont bien vite
mais extrêmement discrète mais pas
seulement comme on est on est des
besogneux tous les deux on est vu tu
peux dire ça mais nous jugerons sur
pièce
voilà comment un macho et une féministe
peuvent-ils s'entendre
j'avais tout faux à la ola le droit
c'était bien ce match où les pieds quand
je leur ai aussi haut que j'aime c'est
eux qui le dit mais non je plaisante pas
bon moi aussi je présente ses électeurs
et paul aussi présentés on plaisante
monory présenteur général quand on dit
qu'ils allaient du sénat et il est
pourquoi je vais pas faire long sur la
sur la revue de presse politique parce
que là les nouvelles du jour
monory au sénat et soissons au
gouvernement c'est passionnant c'est
vraiment la france et est vraiment dans
tous ses états ce soir vous êtes très
gaie et dans la vie vous êtes tous les
deux des êtres peu révolté un peu en
colère
en général quand on s'associe on est on
est dissemblable on se ressemble pas là
dedans la vie vous ressemblent alors
comment ça se passe est-ce que cet
explosif en coulisses par exemple n'ont
bizarrement ça ça c'est vrai pour moi en
tout cas ça s'annule plus tôt moi je
suis très tranquille des deux d'abord
pour pour faire ce spectacle c'est moins
de pression ce mois louant les deux quoi
apporter cette chose et c'est la chose
la plus lourdement arrête avec ça le
connaît on sait que je ne veux des repas
et
j'avais dit explose il est question pas
les rames
on a envie de le garder pendant deux
heures on te paraît si je ne peux pas
rester
après il ya plein de belles choses sur
sur france 2 on les oblige à se séparer
on vous retrouve muriel demain sur
france 2 avec d'autres nana frou frou
frou frou mais vous êtes invités seuls
oui ça va j'ai davantage le travail
d'accord chacun son genre de mire suis
fait tout ce qui est marqué je suis tout
ce qui est des choses je peux plus fait
tout ce qu'il a eu c'est dans la mare du
cirque la cfa tu ce qu'est un peu futile
et elle avoue retrouve dans ce qui est
très important envoyé spécial de
vittorio avec un superbe lorient 13
octobre
mais c'est pas de faire de la pub parce
que je suis bien façon merci guy bedos a
serait monory pour moi je suis ravi pour
lui et je suis ravi que ce soit comme ça
quand même
mais tout ne l'embrassé pas pour eux
s'ils demanderaient ce que pourquoi
lorsqu'une prend donc laissé tomber
merci et bonne soirée est devenue ce
journal est terminée laurent romejko
c'est bien mais je vais pas prendre
cette place là je rêverais en
téléphonant hervé bourges
j'ai un seul à résister non mais là
maintenant je revenais de venir à vichy
comme un sondage il ya des tireurs ont
fusionné je venais donné mais vite parce
que les rennais sont intelligents ils
sont à la fois la lisez ne convient pas
20h50 le film de télévision haute
tension tht et le texte monté mâles 2h30
sportissimo gérard holtz avec marie josé
pérec les catherine ceylac 23 45
les amants de louis malle mini sac même
en mesure à 13h pour toute la semaine
avant que si riom pour son émission
géopolis elle portera de match elle
portera demain sur les afrikales de
france et je vous retrouverai vendredi
prochain painter oui quand vous voulez
qu'est ce qu'il faisait et pourquoi pour
moi
bonsoir j'ai alors ça ça m'a beaucoup
plu